The second disadvantage is in construction,
particularly contention in the construction process.
What we might have is 2 different items,
each of which wants to place 1 item into the hash table.
Let's say both of these items decide
that they have the same hash function for their particular item,
and so they both want to add an item to hash table bucket number 12, for instance.
These 2 items want to simultaneously manipulate the link list in the same bucket.
To do that, they're going to have to serialize and synchronize.
Only 1 of them can update the bucket at any given time,
and the other must wait its turn.
So any serialization like this within a parallel algorithm is definitely undesirable, as well.
So the conclusion here is that chaining
is a sub-optimal strategy if were dealing with parallel hash tables.
So we're going to turn to a different method.